[音楽]
こんにちはー
始めシャツはですね
題名にもあると分かるんだったまん
亜大日にもあると思うんですけれども
私ん
肇社長はん
きょう4月1日は持ちません ua
上に入らせていただきます良い運ってわかりますか
ああ
u 2日本の融通部のあの伝説級の理由もんじゃなくてで月のこの youtube の
動画だして二つ井加工入っている
所属するプロダクションがあるんですけどもう-県産に汗と酸をはじめとした高
プロダクションがあるんですけどそこに所属させていただきます入ったからってこーー
んなに変わる
気じゃないんですけど
結構こうなんか来るんですよいろいろ
ちょっとたわからないと思うけど色々くるんですよ
嘘いるクレーの多くをサポートしてくれたリコ
何かしようと思ったら箱いろいろあるんですよいろいろあってそういうのを大
それしてくれる処理っていうまあサポートですねいろいろしていただくんで本当に今後
は
むーむさんがサポート受けつつ動画を載せていこうと思います
ごろん前にへ
ここまで来たかと動く川鵜の入ったからゴールドバッグには本3万人くらい服後ばいる
というわけですよ
宇野ですけどそれで今後とまで本当に
火が消えさんよろしくをします
[音楽]
瀬戸さんもよろしくお願います
スプーンよってません
ん
4月1日者の
っていうわけ
実はお嫁に入ったって言うのはよそうでした程度を負ったカラーだって上メガ乳月1日
から入りますデューたら
4月1つにいうしかなかったんですよこれはもう本当かどうかを皆さんの目で確かめて
下さいてゆけ
動画の説明欄の下の url ニウムのホームページがあるんで
真実を確認してください
今までレス通りのスタンス+サポートを受けつつもっと4
見てくださる方が入ってありがたいんですけど
リクエストを着ても僕は基本的にシカトするんで
本当に僕がしたいことをやらせていただきます
そしてそれについてくる形はもう全力で監査するんで何でも最後としてねチャンネル
体制が10日これからをついて来ていただきありがとうございますじゃあ
[音楽]